ciao a tutti oggi è il coming out del
adesso serve veramente fare coming out
no in un mondo ideale no non serve in un
mondo in cui non di alcun tipo
discriminazione non sarebbe dove tutti
hanno gli stessi diritti
le persone non si uccidono perché avevo
risultate e dove famoso non è un insulto
e dove l'omosessualità non è un reato
punibile con la pena di morte
quindi sì diciamo che fare coming out un
gesto abbastanza importante quando si
parla di coming out
se non avete una parola buona da
spendere nei confronti le persone che
non potete capire
fate silenzio uno di cui vi parlerò nel
mio viaggio il mio percorso e credo di
averlo sempre avuto chiaro a 14 anni c'è
stato un momento in cui io mi sono detto
ok sono gary cosa hanno detto a posto
allora di anni ne passarono altri 6 con
più di vent'anni ho deciso un pochino di
mettermi sul mercato il giorno dopo ero
fidanzato e pochi mesi dopo ha preso gli
operai su youtube
adesso voglio darvi delle referenze per
farvi capire a livello di tempo che cosa
è successo perché quando ho postato
chiede natalizia che il mio primo video
su youtube
ero fidanzato già da un po non lo sapeva
nessuno a casa né agli unici a saperlo
erano due tre amici strettissimi e mia
cugina da confidente più grande che io
abbia mai avuto
avere una confidente una fortuna enorme
per chiunque abbia qualcosa che non
vuole dire ma di cui ha bisogno di
scooter e da lì sono passati dei mesi e
ricordo che nel periodo in cui postavo
aiello sono iniziati i primi drammi
all'interno dell'area famiglia perché di
colpo questo ragazzino di vent'anni
massimo di spostamenti riusciva a fare a
casa era la divano a letto da letto al
frigo di colpo
non c'era mai a casa e ricordo ancora
una chiacchiera fece con mia madre in
macchina dove mi disse guarda sentivo un
sospetto con sospetto che tu stia con
una persona più grande di te che questa
persona non sia una donna
ricordo che allora dico tutto incazzato
cioè tutto sarà tu mi devi lasciar di
the record avete detto una cosa tipo b o
poi un premio e ricordo anche che mia
madre pianse pianse quelle cose tipo
disperata di auchan dove ho sbagliato io
l'ho sempre saputo anche quando eri
piccola in realtà che dicevo ero piccolo
è capito quando ero piccolo giocato
ma non c'erano le barbe impunito quindi
e da lì s'è aperta la voragine di non
dialogo
mia madre il tempo è passato finché non
arriviamo a eclipse è stato in quel
momento che io ho cercato di parlare con
mio fratello gabriele efficiente volevo
facendo cose tipo gati o di una cosa che
cosa com'è il tempo secondo te e mangi
stasera come ci restiamo al matrimonio
di cinzia non riuscivo a dirglielo ed è
così che arriviamo a finte ubriacature
al momento in cui finalmente sono
riuscito a parlare con i miei fratelli
risposte alabarda monco sapevate
quell'altro ma che non lo sappiamo più
presa per il culo perché tipo quando a
volte deciso dalla mia camera a guardare
i film che conta l'amore la lampada
verso la porta in modo che se uno entra
ma che io ci stavo baciando che ne so
niente di è però ci sono baciando anima
ceca ad ora questo fascio di luce e io
pensavo che nessuno se ne rendesse conto
era palese era lampante da lima spiegato
che in realtà sta solamente aspettando
me un sacco di persone dicono perché se
lo sanno non me lo vengono a dire loro
nel mio caso è perché avevano con lei
farle male temevano che messo all'angolo
io gli avrei mentito e avrebbe fatto
capire che hanno deciso di tagliarli
fuori dalle manopole iniziata risultare
da parte io volevo pirlo con tutte le
mie forze ma dall'altra parte a questo
chiodo di persone mi dicevano no quella
non devi farlo non devi farlo deve
aspettare il momento giusto deve
aspettare di crescere aspettare niente
perché importante perché altrimenti poi
sei fuori se finito continuano a dirmi
non voglio arrivare a 60 anni far dire
cacchio era così semplice ed è stato
quando postai disney hard core che
avvenne un momento in cui nella prima
volta mi sono reso conto che è
l'opinione degli altri mi stava portando
a odiarmi c'è stato un momento in cui
messo davanti allo specchio mi sono
detto che harmont e le persone che
magari possono avere qualcosa contro la
tua sessualità
dov'è che vogliono arrivare cioè
vogliono che tu dica ok faccio come dite
voi anche se non sarò mai felice ed è
stato in quel momento che io mi sono
detto cazzo questo non è amore questo è
un amore malato taglio
e l'opinione gli altri un benefico un
cazzo ho vissuto un momento di così
grande liberazione che forse il primo
discriminarmi aaron io sono successe
delle cose che hanno completamente
sanato il rapporto con mia madre
adesso mi chiede che cosa faccio il mio
ragazzo è triste quando a cena mi
presento io e veloce e tu sei anni è
vero che tu sei impiegato che tu sia
qualunque cosa ci saranno sempre delle
persone contrarie al modo in cui dove
vive la vita
beh la cosa bellissima e che sei te che
decide cosa farne la vita lì è arrivato
un momento che è stato quello che mi
aspettavo che sarebbero arrivati degli
insulti e terapia notte a metà del
[ __ ] almeno si è beccato ma la cosa
assurda è stata che non solo sta
scatenata un'ondata di amore incredibile
ma le persone che mi seguono e che hanno
visto quel video chestanno dopo anni
luce avanti
vorrei chiudere questo video citando mia
non avevo il terrore che lei lo sapesse
lei siamo mia madre disse guarda ho
saputo di guglielmo sentiti di una cosa
io adesso li vogliono ancora più bene ed
è dirgli che fa bene a non andare con le
donne perché le donne sono tutte ed è
stato in quel momento che io ho capito
che se una signora di 80 anni
proveniente da mirabella imbaccari se
poteva arrivare allora nessuno ha
giustificazioni con questi discorsi non
voglio spingere nessuno sa fare niente
perché minuto una cosa seria parlare di
se stessi una cosa seria ed è giusto che
le persone che non si sentono ancora
pronte si possano proteggere a queste
persone mi auguro di trovare chiarezza
auguro di trovare la forza ma
semplicemente auguro di trovare serenità
che sia nel dirlo o nel dirlo perché sto
diventa grandi comunque scialla rilascia
l'accende avete ammazzato qualcuno
e le persone che dicono meglio un figlio
morto che un game casa ci hanno shannon
cimitero in testa